.
THANKS, TRACE.
♪ FOX NEWS ALERT, JUST MOMENTS
AGO ANOTHER BATCH OF THE TWITTER
FILES WAS DROPPED BY JOURNALIST
MATT TIBERIASY.
THIS TIME WE LEARN ABOUT THE
STEPS TWITTER TOOK ON
JANUARY 6TH AND LEADING UP TO
IT.
AND WE'LL SHARE THOSE WITH YOU
IN JUST A MOMENT.
BUT, FIRST, WE ALL KNOW A LAWYER
WHEN WE SEE ONE.
THIS THEY LIE WHEN THEY DON'T
HAVE TO.
LIKE THE GUY IN THE OFFICE
ALWAYS LATE.
YOU KNOW AS SOON AS HE WALKS IN
YOU WILL HEAR A FAKE STORY ABOUT
A WOMAN GIVING BIRTH ON A TRAIN.
IF YOU CALL HIM OUT, THEY WILL
LIE AGAIN AND DO IT STRAIGHT TO
YOUR FACE.
>> NOW WE'RE GOING TO RUN A FEW
TESTS.
THIS IS A SIMPLE LIE DETECTOR.
I WILL ASK YOU A FEW YES OR NO
QUESTIONS AND YOU JUST ANSWER
TRUTHFULLY.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND.
>> YES.
[EXPLOSION]
>> Jesse: THIS IS COMING JUST
AFTER JOURNALIST BARI WEISS
DROPPED NEW TWITTER DOCUMENTS
PROVING THE COMPANY CENSORED
CONSERVATIVES, PEOPLE LIKE DAN
BONGINO, CHARLIE KIRK, LIBS OF
TIKTOK AND EVEN A STANFORD
DOCTOR WHO SAID LOCKDOWNS WOULD
HURT CHILDREN.
WERE SECRETLY SHADOWED BANNED ON
TWITTER.
POSTS BEING PURGED, BURIED,
SECRETLY CENSORED.
MANY CONSERVATIVES WERE
STRAIGHT-UP BEING BANNED.
BONGINO HAD PEOPLE TELLING HIM
THEY COULDN'T FIND HIM ON
TWITTER.
AND BONGINO IS THE MOST VIRAL
GUY ON FACEBOOK BUT HE WAS A
GHOST ON TWITTER SOME WEEKS.
NO ONE COULD SEE HIM.
THE MEDIA TOLD US WE WERE
IMAGINING THINGS.
HEADLINE AFTER HEADLINE TOLD US
MOVE ALONG, THERE'S NOTHING TO
SEE HERE.
EVERY REPORTER SAID TWITTER
ISN'T SHADOW BANNING
REPUBLICANS.
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE.
THE CEO AT THE TIME, JACK DORSEY
EVEN WENT UNDER OATH TO SAY THE
SAME THING.
>> SOCIAL MEDIA IS BEING RIGGED
TO CENSOR CONSERVATIVES.
IS THAT TRUE OF TWITTER?
>> NO.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TWITTER IS
UP TO.
IT SURE LOOKS LIKE TO ME THEY
ARE CENSORING PEOPLE AND THEY
OUGHT TO STOP IT.
ARE YOU CENSORING PEOPLE.
>> NO.
>> TWITTER SHADOW BANNING
PROMINENT REPUBLICANS, BAD.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NO.
>> Jesse: TURNS OUT HE LIED
UNDER OATH, LIED CONGRESS, WHICH
IS SUPPOSED TO BE A CRIME AND HE
LIED TO YOU.
TWITTER WASN'T JUST CENSORING
CONSERVATIVE SPEAKERS, ELON SAID
TODAY THEY WERE EVEN CENSORING
REPUBLICAN POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS.
MILLIONS OF VOTERS AND
CONSTITUENTS COULDN'T SEE WHAT
REPUBLICAN CAMPAIGNS WERE
SAYING.
OR WHAT REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS
WERE SAYING.
AND WHILE THIS WAS HAPPENING,
DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS, DEMOCRAT
CAMPAIGNS WERE PUMPED STRAIGHT
INTO YOUR BLOODSTREAM.
$40 BILLION COMPANY RIGGED
AMERICA'S POLITICAL DEBATE TO
HELP THEIR PREFERRED POLITICAL
PARTY.
A PRIVATE COMPANY WAS DOING
POLITICAL FAVORS FOR DEMOCRAT
CANDIDATES.
ELECTION LAWS WERE BROKEN.
ELECTIONS WERE INTERFERED WITH.
TWITTER WAS PROVIDING IN KIND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DEMOCRAT
CANDIDATES.
AND NONE OF THIS WAS DISCLOSED.
IT WAS ALL DONE IN THE DARK.
AND REPUBLICAN FUNDRAISING WAS
AFFECTED.
DEMOCRACY WAS POISONED.
THE FORMER CEO JACK DORSEY KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS DOING.
AND HE HAD AN ARMY OF LOBBYISTS
DOMINATING DEMOCRAT REGULATORS
IN D.C. SO HE COULD GET AWAY
WITH IT.
>> I THINK OFTENTIMES COMPANIES
SEE THEMSELVES AS REACTING TO
REGULATION AND I THINK WE NEED
TO TAKE MORE OF AN EDUCATION
ROLE.
SO I DON'T FEAR IT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
EDUCATING REGULATORS ON WHAT'S
POSSIBLE, WHAT WE ARE SEEING AND
WHERE WE COULD GO.
>> WHEN YOU SAY EDUCATING
REGULATORS THAT'S INITIATING
REGULATION.
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
WE MIGHT JUST BE TALKING.
>> EDUCATING REGULATORS.
WHO ARE THESE REGULATORS?
>> THESE ARE FOLKS WHO WHO MIGHT
BE TASKED WITH COME UP WITH A
PROPOSAL PARTICULAR LEGISLATION
OR LAWS TO LEGISLATORS.
>> Jesse: SO TWITTER OWNED
WASHINGTON.
WHERE IS THE FBI TRADITIONALLY
THE BUREAU WOULD INVESTIGATE
POLITICAL CORRUPTION.
BUT THE FBI WAS IN ON IT.
TWITTER'S TOP LAWYER JAMES BAKER
WAS A FORMER FBI LAWYER.
HE WAS PLANTED AT THE COMPANY TO
OVERSEE POLITICAL CENSORSHIP
AFTER SUCCESSFULLY ORCHESTRATING
THE RUSSIA HOAX.
AS ELON WAS DROPPING THESE NEW
DOCUMENTS HE INTERCEPTED THEM
AND STARTED SCRUBBING DOCUMENTS
WERE DELETED.
THIS FORMER FBI LAWYER DESTROYED
COMPANY PROPERTY AND DESTROYED
EVIDENCE.
REMEMBER, IN 2016, HIS TEAM
FABRICATED EVIDENCE AGAINST
TRUMP AND NOW HE IS DESTROYING
EVIDENCE TO HELP BIDEN.
THAT'S AN FBI LAWYER.
PLUS, BAKER WASN'T THE ONLY FED
WORKING THERE, TWITTER
HEADQUARTERS WAS SWIMMING WITH
EXCIA AND FBI AGENTS.
THEY ALL HAD SUITE OFFICES AND
HELD TOP COMPANY POSITIONS.
THE HEAD OF TWITTER STRATEGIC
RESPONSE TEAM, JEFF CARLTON
WORKED FOR BOTH THE CIA AND THE
FBI.
IS THAT A COINCIDENCE?
WAS TWITTER BEING USED AS A BACK
END GOVERNMENT PROGRAM?
WAS TWITTER BEING USED AS A
SURVEILLANCE PLATFORM AN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATION, A PSY
OPS PROGRAM?
HAS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY JOINED
FORCES WITH AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE TO SUBVERT
ELECTIONS AND CRUSH AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVES?
AND THE CORPORATE MEDIA NOT ONLY
WON'T TOUCH THE SCANDAL, BUT
THEY WILL SCANDALIZE ANY
REPORTER WHO REPORTS IT.
WHEN JACK DORSEY BREEZES THROUGH
INTERVIEWS ON CNN, IT ALL MAKES
SENSE.
>> REAL QUESTION BEHIND THE
QUESTION IS ARE WE DOING
SOMETHING ACCORDING TO POLITICAL
IDEOLOGY OR VIEWPOINTS?
AND WE ARE NOT.
PERIOD.
WE DO NOT LOOK AT CONTENT WITH
REGARDS TO POLITICAL VIEWPOINT
OR IDEOLOGY.
WE NEED TO CONSTANTLY SHOW THAT
WE ARE NOT ADDING OUR OWN BIAS,
WHICH I FULLY ADMIT IS MORE LEFT
LEANING.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS ALL A LIE.
HOW MANY LIES CAN YOU TELL ON
CNN AND GET AWAY WITH IT?
TWITTER WAS HELPING DEMOCRATS
SUPPRESS THE VOTES AND SWAY
ELECTIONS.
BIG TECH, BIG MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE WHY PEOPLE DON'T
TRUST ELECTIONS.
AND THE SADDEST PART ABOUT ALL
OF THIS, IS WHILE THEY WERE
SUPPRESSING POLITICAL SPEECH,
THEY WERE CENSORING DOCTORS.
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO WERE
BANNED FOR WARNING THAT
LOCKDOWNS WOULD HURT KIDS.
THAT SCHOOL CLOSURES WOULD HURT
KIDS.
HERE'S ONE OF THE TOP DOCTORS
WHO WAS THROTTLED BY FAUCI AND
TWITTER.
>> IT REALLY HURT PUBLIC HEALTH.
IF WE HAD AN OPEN DISCUSSION,
LAURA, THE SCHOOLS WOULD NOT
HAVE CLOSED IN THE FALL OF 2020.
IF WE HAD AN OPEN DISCUSSION,
THE LOCKDOWNS WOULD HAVE BEEN
LIFTED MUCH EARLIER BECAUSE THE
DATA AND EVIDENCE BEHIND THEM
WAS SO BAD.
TWITTER, BY SUPPRESSING
SCIENTIFIC DISCUSSION HARMED
SCIENCE, HARMED CHILDREN, AND
HARMED THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
IMAGINE HOW DIFFERENT ALL THE
SMALL BUSINESSES COU HAVE
STAYED OPEN.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WOULDN'T
HAVE MISSED THEIR CANCER
SCREENINGS.
ALL THE KIDS THAT WOULDN'T BE
DEPRESSED AND SUICIDAL.
ALL THE LEARNING LOSS THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED IF WE JUST HAD
AN OPEN SCIENTIFIC DISCUSSION.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS THE POINT.
THEY WANTED CONTROL, NOT
DISCUSSION.
FROM POLITICS TO SCIENCE.
THEY WANTED TO BE THE JUDGE,
JURY, AND EXECUTIONN